Вітаю!
Ми з вами на уроці географії.
Мене звати Чемеріс Світлана.
І сьогодні ми починаємо
вивчати тему “Води суходолу”.
Води суходолу — це
продовження теми "Гідросфера",
яку ви почали вивчати і
вивчали світовий океан.
До вод суходолу відносяться:
Увага на екран!
Кількість вод суходолу
залежить від клімату,
рельєфу та гірських порід місцевості.
Якщо кількість опадів на
території перевищує випаровування,
то вода, яка залишається, стікає в
річки, втікає в природні заглибини,
утворюючи озера або в твердому
стані нагромаджується у льодовиках.
Переходимо до вивчення річки.
Що ж таке річка?
Річка — це природний водний потік,
що тече у виробленій ним заглибині.
Будь-яка річка має свій початок.
Початок річки ми називаємо витоком.
Як бачимо на схемі,
ось у нас витік цієї річки.
Витоком може бути підземне
джерело, болото, льодовик або озеро.
Наприклад, наша
головна річка країни Дніпро
бере початок у болоті
на Валдайській височині.
Іноді річка губиться, не доносить
води до якогось іншого водного об'єкту.
Тоді ви можете бачити її
на карті пунктирною лінією,
такі річки у нас позначають пунктиром.
Можете подивитися на карту Австралії,
тут є декілька прикладів таких річок.
Місце, де річка впадає в якийсь
водний об'єкт, називається гирло.
Гирлом може бути інша річка або море,
океан, також гирлом може бути озеро.
Якщо річка утворює декілька
рукавів і цими рукавами впадає в інший
водний об'єкт, як тут показано,
такі гирла називаються дельта.
Про утворення дельти
ми поговоримо пізніше,
на наступному уроці.
Довжина річки вважається
від витоку до гирла
і може досягати сотні, а в
деяких випадках, і тисячі кілометрів.
Найдовші річки на планеті —
це річка Ніл, ви бачите
її довжину на карті,
Міссісіпі з притокою Міссурі,
і Амазонка.
Річка з усіма своїми притоками
утворює річкову систему.
Притоки бувають ліві або праві.
Яким же чином визначити,
які з приток річки ліві, які праві?
Треба стати таким чином,
щоб ви повторювали напрям
течії, від витоку до гирла.
Відповідно де буде ваша ліва рука,
будуть ліві притоки, де
права — праві притоки.
Ми визначаємо праві і
ліві притоки за течією річки.
Ще які є елементи річкової долини?
Наприклад, та заглибина, в якій
безпосередньо, постійно течуть річкові води,
називається русло або річище.
Річки, які впадають в головну
річку, називаються притоки.
І річкова долина — це
пониження, в якому тече річка.
На нашій схемі показана річкова долина.
Та частина річкової
долини, яка затоплюється
або може бути затоплена річковими водами,
називається заплава.
Ширина русла і ширина
долини можуть бути різні.
Наприклад, ширина долини Дніпра на
території України може досягати 18 км.
Залежно від рельєфу річки
бувають рівнинні і гірські.
Вони відрізняються між собою
швидкістю течії і шириною долини.
Наприклад, гірські річки, як ми бачимо на
зображенні, як правило, не глибокі,
долина у них вузька, часто може
бути з крутими схилами, а течія стрімка.
Коли річка виходить на
рівнину, то течія її сповільнюється.
Чим більше річка приймає
приток, тим ширше стає русло річки,
тому рівнинні річки мають широкі
глибокі долини з більш спокійною течією.
Якщо виходять в руслі тверді породи,
то ми бачимо, що утворюються пороги.
Якщо ж на шляху
річки є уступ, то вода падає
з уступу, утворюючи
таким чином водоспади.
Вся територія, з якої річка збирає
свої води, називається річковий басейн.
Найбільший басейн у світі
має річка Амазонка і його площа
складає близько 7-ми
мільйонів квадратних кілометрів.
Ось ми бачимо на схемі басейн цієї річки.
Є ще одне поняття, яке
пов'язане з будовою річки
і з межею між двома річковими басейнами.
Межа, яка відокремлює два
сусідніх басейни, називається вододіл.
Вододілами, як правило,
виступають або гірські хребти,
якщо це гірська місцевість, або, наприклад,
найвищі точки місцевості на рівнині.
Ми можемо розглянути межу
на материку Північна Америка —
це скелясті гори.
З одного боку на захід
течуть річки в Тихий океан
і на схід річки течуть
в Атлантичний океан.
Давайте перейдемо до живлення річок.
Живлення - це джерела
надходження води в річку.
Звідки річка може брати свої води?
Живлення може бути дощове, снігове,
льодовикове, підземними водами та мішане.
Всі опади, які випадають у вигляді
дощу і потім стікають у водні об'єкти,
становлять дощове живлення.
Таке живлення переважає
в екваторіальних широтах.
Якщо річка має декілька джерел живлення,
наприклад, як в помірних
широтах наші річки України
мають декілька джерел
живлення - і підземними водами,
і талими сніговими водами, і дощовими.
Таке живлення буде називатися мішане.
В засушливих регіонах річки
часто живляться підземними водами.
А талими льодовиковими водами живляться
річки, які починаються високо в горах.
Наприклад, річки Азії
беруть початок високо в горах
і живляться талими льодовиковими водами.
Інше поняття, з яким ви повинні
ознайомитися — це режим річки.
Режим річки — це регулярні
зміни рівня та кількості води в річці.
Протягом року на річці може
бути повінь, паводок і межень.
Повінь — очікуване щорічне відносно
тривале підвищення рівня води.
Після зими сніг, який
випав за холодний сезон,
починає танути і талі
води стікають в річки.
Тому рівень в річках підвищується і
це буває кожного року в певний період.
Тому ми очікуємо підвищення рівня
води в річках саме після танення снігів.
Таке очікуване підвищення
рівня і називається повінь
І річка може виходити з
берегів, як показано на картинках.
Паводок — це теж
підвищення рівня води, однак,
підвищення раптове,
неочікуване, непрогнозоване
Його можуть спричинити
сильні зливи або тривалі опади,
або сніг, який випав, потім
розтанув і вода стекла в річки.
Тому паводок — короткочасні
раптові підняття рівня води.
Межень — найнижчий рівень води в річці.
Влітку, коли кількість опадів зменшується,
а випаровування стає сильнішим,
рівень води в річках зменшується.
Також взимку живлення річки
переважно підземними водами,
тому рівень води зменшується
і настає зимова межень.
Таким чином, у нас є межень
два рази на рік — літня і зимова.
На цьому ми з вами
новий матеріал закінчуємо.
Пролунав дзвоник.
Наступного разу ми вивчимо
тему "Озера. Болота. Підземні води"
Ваше домашнє завдання -
уважно ще раз прочитайте матеріал
вашого підручника з відповідної теми.
До побачення!